（急いでいる人は1：20まで飛ばしましょう）
このまま寝ると企画が終わっちまう
起きろ、はじめ
俺にはこの企画をクリアするというミッションがあるんだ
やるしかねー！
こんにちは
寝る直前です　はじめしゃちょーです
ただいまの時刻、午前の4時9分でございます
いやーーー…
もう朝ですね（笑）
寝るのが今日遅くなっちゃって、
明日
で！僕もね、いくら寝起きがいいからといって
確実に短い睡眠時間でねバッと起きれるんですけど、
やっぱ、キツいんすよ　どうしてもキツい
起きれるんですけど、起きた後よ！問題は！起きた後！
また寝ちゃうんです…
ちゃんと起きれるよ　バシッと起きれてね　もう余裕で動けるんですけど、
眠いじゃん
結局寝たい　やっぱ寝れるもんなら寝たい
その欲に負けて僕は何度も二度寝したことか…
明日は絶対起きなきゃいけないんで、
そんな起きなきゃいけない日のために
私はとある準備をしました
目覚まし時計についてめちゃくちゃ調べた結果、
恐らく世界最強レベル！
市販で発売している目覚まし時計で最強レベルの
目覚まし時計は、これだ！というものに辿り着きました
うわ、これは　うるさそうだな～
うるさそうだよ
これ、絶対SUPERでしょ
こちらのスーパーライデンという目覚ましが、
口コミとか超調べたよ
これ多分事実上、世界最強の目覚まし時計です
（目覚まし時計の音）
うわーーーー！
やばい
お前これ嘘でしょ　バケモンじゃん
（目覚まし時計の音）
これ、一個でいいかな？
いや、そういうわけにもいかねーよ
10個、準備させていただきました
時刻は5時39分
すべての時計の設定をしていると、
一時間以上経っていました…
死にそうです
電波時計なんですけど、何個か調子悪くて設定できなくて
手動で設定しました　すべて完璧なタイミングになっております
もーーーー
早く寝たかったのに、設定したら一時間以上経ってんだよ
YouTuberも大変だよ
もう6時かよ　くそったれが
明日はですね、
起きることも大事なんですけど、それ以上にですね
この最強の目覚まし10個あるとどんな音色がするのか
それを一番知りたいんですよ僕は
そう起きることはね、二の次でね
最強の目覚ましが10個あるとね、どうなっちゃうのかというのをちょっと体験したいんで
すべてのタイマーを9時に設定することが出来ました
はい、後は寝るだけでございます
では早速、寝に行きましょう
6時2分
恐怖に震えながら　眠ります
おやすみー
（目覚まし時計の音）
うわ！うわ！うわ！うわ！
あ！あ！あ…
ハァ　ハァ
ふぅ…
終わった